start welcome to this video playing hmm
dear in its all renika come from Norway
it seems we got the perks offense ie6 oh
that's that's fairly uncommon okay I
guess exchanging this Bishop cannot be
too bad this is one idea after the whole
setup after all maybe I can't even get
in a cubic h4 h5 hmm i might want to
retreat her some special but still why
not H form f3 and g4 comes into mind
like in the dragon okay preparing h5 he
seems very confident that his setup here
is resilient is it h5 very dangerous
already okay
okay you are before I can just go to you
too there's no big problem here if I
take F takes Bishop g7 tweenage six lets
us are fairly dangerous really hmm or is
it better to to go for some other other
move order it's also possibly five and
94 yeah I probably should should do that
anyway Queen age six then and then
probably five if you have to have the e4
square for the noid check yar 94 to have
an active square for the noise is
playing amazingly quickly as it really
is so easy everything ok g5 is one good
news tending Knight f6 song
maybe just one good good way to play um
can I def six now you can also just take
d6 now let's just let's just take this
grab grab the pawn with a good position
yeah rook chicks I guess keeping the H
file open to grab another pawn
threatening 96 yeah sure but i really i
really like my position here it's a pawn
and no particular counter play Bishop
just here Rock h1 or should I push in
five maybe not sure but okay but I
Mercer is getting somewhat lower zone if
I double here on the edge fold it does
not really does not really need too much
probably rather make sure I have a good
piece harmonies king in the middle okay
he probably should play a five year I
mean it is not really helping him so
much but otherwise i'll play you find
myself yes I came but this is still very
nice for wide yeah I can take you five
simply rookie 794 and they have f 6
which is not really a bad square
okay so maybe now okay threatens to
check here and play 95 this is probably
the easiest solution I it's a check it's
a check on the fiber this is stupid I
always thought you cannot take because
of 90 m but I forgot I forgot about this
month um I can maybe play six here can I
not esox intermediate meals I think I
can
transverse was a bit unnecessary to to
have this sort of complications I it
should be a win ready if you move the
night this Knight f6
yeah Midas attics and now taking its d6
winning not sure now let's let's keep
the material here time morning king d
for now check yeah but I have I have
total control of the points here King e5
and e6
okay now can i play a seven and rook
everyone or not maybe I should just just
take here first it's probably much
easier now here non-threatening d 787
check
cal king of aids just e7 who takes rook
takes jack jump 30 seconds should should
be ok probably just Rock g7 and the
h-bond it's the easiest with a slow time
check
check giant promotes just keep keep
jamming
check and mate I guess checkmate let's
check the sign I wasn't as usual pretty
amazed how quickly you played all this
and it's quite clear that black ears
already almost lost compass on plus 2.7
the tickets just just far too much so
candy not the best way that I played our
Kim still plus two so it's probably
probably okay so g5 and now our queen
edge form is even more convincing or
queen h2 we are Queen edge too I guess
that's better keeping the Queen's on and
still having night f6 if you look at
this this is quite nice Fifi take so I
cannot really do any of this or this I
can play a lot of 6 sent and win the
house now this is terrible Knight f6 is
this just devastating check on something
something like that it's not the only
line right here okay i took it seems to
keep at least a big advantage of plus 2
probably i played i didn't play it
perfectly but always keep the huge
action here maybe here I could have done
better that's clear and this is a
mistake in comparison it's still plus 3
but and now here you 6 is probably
nonsense King takes us is much easier
check
I can just play that that's true those
two pawns will decide the game + + 3
point something and is six ok it keeps a
baguette right here check here I
probably did something stupid took here
and now be 3m still plus 4 yeah I shot
that the points what is side and then
they do but okay it was a bit more
complicated than necessary those pawns
are too strong it's still plus 4 or
something check so while I didn't play
as down and then the best way it was
still a convincing punishment of the
opening yeah well those hyper modern
stuff is is interesting but you cannot
neglect the center all the time
especially it's a little bit like
playing um yeah I'm waving a big stick
at him with age four and he's doing
nothing nothing against it and he is
already very difficult stock for she is
already a plus 2.5 yeah the attackers is
very strong okay thanks for watching